i think zach might have grabbed his knee  and helped him trip  you think or no oh he just punched yeah  he did and wow he just punched  that was like tyson's punch out oh my  goodness he just punched yeah  he got mad and just i don't think he did  it on purpose he was upset with not  getting the call and swung his fist and  he hit lonzo  watch i mean he was a whirlwind right he  was just oh yeah he did oh wow  i'll tell you what no one ever accused  lonzo not being able to take a punch  because that might have not that might  have been like some rudy tom jonathan's  thing right there that could have been  ugly  watch boom  wow  yeah he just got broadsided now the  officials are gonna talk it over  wow  that's definitely a flavor and foul just  said can we do some layups now warm up  well it's been a while so it is a  technical foul  it's on embiid  good sport right there telling me i  didn't mean to do that it was an  accident just you know my fault man  good sportsmanship